california california california
the middle class famous tour is coming
to the left coast yeah guys april we're
gonna be in san francisco april fourth
we're gonna be in los angeles april six
we're gonna be in la jolla get your
tickets now it's a little bit of stand
up it's a little bit of ayg it's a whole
lot of fun do it
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r u garbage here it's a little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find out if they grow up to be
classy yeah or if they're just a big old
piece of trash i'm listening i'm your
host dave trolley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're down here at
antoni's basement caught her coming out
of the shower a couple of minutes ago
yeah not too shabby tight little body on
that one t.o.b on tuddy yeah my co-host
is coming at you from across the table
it's a family episode we're circling the
wagons once again here with uh the gang
the squad the homies the bozo from the
road back from the road florida atlanta
that was it
that was it when we came back two cities
in two cities in florida hey we're not
journey what the [ __ ] you want from us
okay give it up for our good pal
kevin james ryan hey thank you literally
forgot your name oh yeah oh man the the
big man's all in one today
that shaved the beard i think all your
funny bone went away looks like you got
bitter beer face all the time now
where's the beef yeah
it looks like it looks like your bottom
[ __ ] bottom half of your face is
going i feel like the mom from goonies
shout out the [ __ ] your brother uh guys
what's up thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you review subscribe on
itunes file video available on youtube
and as you know those numbers are true
uh obviously patreon.com the greatest
website of all time uh
i mean what do you have to say about
that i i think we just cracked three
zillion hours of content over there on
patreon it was two trillion and then the
numbers came across three zillion wow
yeah sign up you get bonus episodes ayg
episodes of hard feelings which by the
way is the pod
that's the real money steamy over there
ayg after dark yeah hard feeling is a
good time then the live streams
obviously thank you so much guys
absolutely love yous love yous mean it
love yous got la coming up la la land
let's sell it out let's sell out los
angeles la jolla listen and san fran
what do you say you don't got a lot of
time so get those ticks i don't know
about san fran it holds about 500
but listen everybody's been climbing
come out we've been posting dates for
the past year come out to l.a gotta come
out to the west coast don't [ __ ]
embarrass me when i go out there for the
first time got the suits coming we gotta
come correct there's gonna be some
industry there hanging out we gotta sell
the tickets get your friends people in
florida and atlanta were coming up to us
yo i was going to buy one ticket but i
got i got the crew together i stumbled
the trash squad came out
everybody has a good time it's a fun
time it's a fun time first of all shout
out to everybody in atlanta in florida
thank you [ __ ] love that's solid
eared people good times out there yeah
tell you what that floor date looking
too bad dude i'll tell i can move to
florida right now
that's steve desantis or whatever his
name is starts making a lot of sense
when you're down there for a couple
hours i'll tell you that right now that
sunshine is all i need how about a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good got his own cam coming
soon
give it up for t-bone mcmuffin toby
mcmullen what up dudes what up people
get a little color on you yeah hell yeah
dude you can start hitting hollywood
real quick a muppet back there you look
like the penguin what are you talking
about
[ __ ] big mouth billy bass over there
there's a tie which i just saw at my
house last night i want to say you
posted a picture of it i want to say
this about that about the beard number
one i apologize if you're eating during
this broadcast um i just realized you
had so many nooks and crannies on your
face yikes looks like a thomas another
set of teeth below the chin
man you got a big pool
jacket jowls like a sperm whale i don't
know
like a [ __ ] bulldog in a cartoon
looks like it's just thick neck on this
one i feel like i should be shaking down
tom the cat right now looks like it
looks like you should have a tire i'm
napping over here see you should have a
tire in your mouth wigging it back and
forth like a pit bull
you should be in a dmx music video right
now
spike chain on being held back
some hot chick in a bikini
uh i started to trim it because it was
getting real
it was it was bad down here and i was
[ __ ] biting the sides and pulling
them out and i really started to do that
yeah oh dude it's i try not to do it and
i would just find myself uh i was like
yes i'd be trying to talk to you i'd be
trying to talk to you about banking or
something i look over you you're chewing
on your facial hair
this is this is my cfo over here folks
trying to have a board meeting he's
eating himself the worst one you had in
your mask and it would you'd take your
mask off and half of it would be going
up and the other half would be going
down dude
i apologize again for my disgustingness
but i tried to trim it to get it under
control
i tried to trim it to get under control
and you know just one thing led to
another i've been there with my pupils
see them
i taped all that stuff down there
[Laughter]
my little guy's in there like a sniper
yeah you've never seen him he's coming
he's got a guillotine
he'll be dead before you hear the shot
holy cow yeah but back from the road
we're here for a family episode we love
you guys we can't thank you enough um i
have two questions for you because i was
down here in miami i'm here to answer
these questions you've mentioned right i
was down there in miami in a place i
shouldn't have been in all right it was
real nice a gym
it's at the gym this morning tough guy
i'll take you out there right now do
some sumo squats on you i bet you i
could bench press you what are you
i know what we're doing on patreon after
that
grab that little wiener
get some no get some chalk on my hands
you lebron
um a hotel we should i i shouldn't have
been i shouldn't have stayed at just for
attractive you shouldn't be in a motel
six i know in tuscaloosa
let alone a nice one in miami dude the
plymouth hotel in miami [ __ ]
beautiful the pool hanging out nice
people well to do people [ __ ]
attractive everybody's minding their own
business relaxing having a good time um
i wanted to ask you something about that
but first i wanted to ask you what did
you have a pizza cutter in your house
growing up oh no really
yeah we cut it all with [ __ ] the
ginsu i always thought that was real
[ __ ] nice that's real classy and now
it's like you're doing elios and pennies
now it's like wait what because that's
how they demo the knives they cut
pennies in half it took me a minute when
i got there
i thought you meant i was cutting the
helios with a penny ah too fast for you
who wrote that saul what the [ __ ]
whatever jigsaw that's what i was
thinking what is this thing from the
movie i was thinking this all movies oh
man you two are vacation brains i'll
tell you that right now i don't know
what to do the beard's got me all
[ __ ] the beard's got me all twisted i
don't know i feel like i'm broken the
new guy over here i didn't realize how
bad my skin was too and that's
i don't look good
i don't look i tried to get some color
in my pin looks like it has udders on it
or at least it should that thing's
hanging like a pregnant belly on a dog
like an extra in the mandalorian i think
i see a paul in there
i know it's [ __ ] me up too
i made me realize what's your girl say
not happy no no no man not even a little
bit can't be it's like until windows
that's a bad look dude i realize how
yellow my teeth are now it's the whole
thing's bad i got my collagen water with
me though oh that'll help yeah i want to
get pretty for l.a well this isn't the
way
you should you should you should have
covered your eyes somehow too
i want to get pretty it for la so i
exposed every nook and cranny on my face
well i told you i didn't mean to do this
on purpose it just happened i got a
tootsie roll stuck in my beard
i got gum stuck in there
found my keys though goddamn silly putty
oh i love a good scene you should just
let it grow out until then and you'll be
all right yeah i will yeah well god does
patchy and my [ __ ] razor stinks
whatever it doesn't matter
that's why you should use manscape
maybe not this one
but there's people over there they're
typically good people
uh so what were you saying
i was that's the question the question
oh the pizza cutter
thank you uh no now we have one a knife
really that's a cliff my mom does a nice
one like a stainless steel b well i feel
like back and i've mentioned this before
i think or this is just my take on like
then that [ __ ] was like
28 bucks or i felt like now they're like
a nickel right i felt like that stuff
those kind of consumer products were
more expensive back then because less
people used them yeah but now it's like
every kitchen has a [ __ ] pizza cutter
but back in the 90s i was a holy fool
would you steal that from [ __ ] aldos
or something yeah we never even had an
ice cream scooper it was always a
[ __ ] tablespoon we did have one for a
little while with the click what yeah we
got it through my everybody's tried to
sell cutco that's right guys that's rich
guy [ __ ] right there well it's like oh
that's like a sunday bar i know a cousin
or whatever would [ __ ] be selling cut
going on be like all right i'll take the
pitch and you know spend a hundred bucks
with him yeah i'll throw throw to get a
bone or something well that wasn't
working with paddy yeah
she only bought skin so soft that's the
only thing she purchased oh the sss that
spray yeah yeah that's that smell it was
like a [ __ ] mosquito magnet
did it keep it away no it was supposed
to who's gonna who's gonna be able to
avoid that sweet smell
not them sticky mug
oh yeah a little piece of me
uh
what i wanted to ask you was do you
think it's trashy to get to the hotel
real early
knowing that the room's not gonna cause
you guys got there at about 9 15 a.m
early you got out there before the
people even checked out you were hanging
out in the lobby with your bags that's
that's what i'm saying man
yeah because you check they hold the
bags
and then you use the amenities at the
hotel
but it's like people can you know like
i'm out in the pool and like a pair of
cargo pants
you got your luggage at the pool
hey i'm gonna go with the high dive
watch my
sitting in the shades lounge with a neck
pillow fresh from the port
yeah yeah it's a tough look because i
got this vibe when i was like man should
we be doing this
like we should we should have went out
to eat or something
you don't want a bird i'd say you feel
like a burden and you're weird and
you're not really there i don't know it
just really hit me this time i trashy of
a movie you feel like you gotta jump
like i feel like i'd have to justify
myself to the other guests like i'm
still waiting to check it you know i
don't you you feel you don't feel like
you belong no you don't feel like you
feel like you're visiting and i feel
like they know it yeah they do but maybe
we just think that because we're [ __ ]
i don't know what dirtbags do don't
deserve anything they were looking at me
like i was ahead of maintenance the
whole weekend you know what's a real
confidence booster though leaving that
orlando airport in the morning seeing
all those disney folks on the way out oh
yeah yeah i was feeling good about
myself why what do you mean oh dude just
just slobs everywhere yeah a lot of
disney adults hanging out mickey ears
doing shots at the airport bar at 7 00
a.m tough luck
guys get it together all right what the
[ __ ] are we doing you're adults get a
kid go
we look forward to going just the three
of us in a few months
[Laughter]
no children for content purposes um yeah
no that's that's the tough yeah you
gotta you gotta try to plan it but i get
you were hemmed up yeah we're hemmed up
um i did this i was i was at home
visiting a family yesterday down there
uh did you yeah you'll shoot down there
for a day
[Music]
i gotta get i like to have a night's
sleep i don't like driving making that
drive i don't know why that tickled my
funny bones so much you'll shoot down
there for a day yeah well you'd go down
there for lunch and drive back we did we
were down there for maybe two and a half
hours and then you zip right back huh
yeah we had the dog we took the dog down
ah i thought the dog couldn't go
anywhere well he's not allowed
yeah uh they say he's not allowed but
he's not a lot around other dogs well
there's been no dogs in my mom's house
in [ __ ] 15 years i don't think
rusty's sent still laying around
um
so we took him down there let him run
through the yard and stuff like that but
uh
what on the way home cause we've been
going through paper towels like it's
[ __ ] crazy with this dog pissing and
[ __ ] everywhere you dump in the car
no he might have peed yeah yeah but if
we had him in a bag
with a bag hefty
no we them in like a like a like an
overnight there's an engineer's bag in
the back having him in like an overnight
bag he was like hey because we can't we
can't walk in the city carry on we don't
have all these shots yeah so we gotta
you know travel you know a little
carrying bag whatever i'm saying i'm
dude we're going through like three
rolls of toilet paper
toilet paper i mean uh paper towels a
day this thing's between like what i use
cooking you know wiping whatever this
thing's pissing and [ __ ] all over
the place i want a way out of my mom's
there was like two
36
count [ __ ] things of paper towel top
of the for somewhere in the garage and
there go through this there's like a
wall i was like a throne of paper towels
bounty the good stuff the big double
rolls yeah yeah i walked with about five
or six of them really yeah and i was
like i was like oh [ __ ] we'll grab them
for the car then i'm like grab them one
for the car and i'm like maybe one for
the hal maybe two for the house and then
my brother-in-law walked out i'm like ah
i'm just uh just checking this stuff out
dude i call it stealing from my parents
as a 35 year old man however the [ __ ]
old i am
caught stealing paper towels from my
parents that was a tough luck that in a
pair of jumper cables
a case of water
[ __ ] dirt bag it's crazy though
because it's flush down there they got
it they're like preppers
these boomers are like prep
[ __ ] paper towels in the rafters down
here
everything you need
and i think it's the space because we
for me to buy a [ __ ] 36 roll of
[ __ ] paper towel i'd have to get a
new apartment there's nowhere to keep
that logically really you know what i
mean my mother has an endless supply of
uh
like tote bags insulated and on and
uninsulated and an endless supply of
tupperware and glassware yeah because
every time i leave there i got a [ __ ]
you know i got like five bags filled
with sure take these and just put it in
the freezer and here's some soup base
and here's this and there's that ah
we'll bring it back we'll bring it back
[ __ ] not end up throwing that [ __ ]
out yeah yeah i know i don't know where
the [ __ ] she gets it from she probably
steals it she's got sticky fingers at
one and you know it
oh we were talking her in the car and on
the patreon or in florida where did she
steal it from i don't know somewhere who
knows she's a crafty brawn just combing
the beaches
in the summer
hiding under an umbrella just moves
every couple of feet she's in a bush
um no she gets them from legitimate
purchases
uh that's an uh
that's another thing now in new york you
have to purchase a bag or bring a bag i
like it i just want to say you like what
i i don't give a [ __ ] about the dollar
or whatever it is for the best i'll give
you 15 bucks the best i look like a
schmuck carry my belongings out of the
store because if you're walking with
like a [ __ ] watermelon a bag of
couscous a [ __ ] thing of turkey
that's the thing i don't you look like a
[ __ ] jerk do you need a bag or do you
juggle yeah i know yeah that's the thing
that throw me a chainsaw when i say so
[ __ ] out of here man that's it look out
of there do a bags 50 cents a dolla walk
out of there like a [ __ ] gentleman
with some dignity i get the good ones
the ones with like the drawings that
people walk into the store buy everybody
bags i don't care and the other ones
ain't that bad either the i don't know
what the [ __ ] they're made out of but
just the ones they're supposed to just
give you they're all right too they're
like almost cloth i don't think they
they're not supposed they get whacked
for them oh you do
oh my deli around the corner they
[ __ ] just give them to you out of
delis play by their own rules but here's
the thing supermarkets i love that i
love buying the tote it's so much easier
yeah right just throw them out whatever
whatever we're supposed to be doing with
them we're not it's backfiring and you
gave us better bags yeah that's the only
[ __ ] thing i don't think they're
plastic that's the thing what the [ __ ]
are they
who am i elon musk i don't [ __ ] the
thing that bothers me
is like you said is the asking
did you want a bag what am i a [ __ ]
jerk a suit listen cashiers assume i
want a bag and no receipt from here on
out mark my [ __ ] territory my mark my
words i don't need a [ __ ] receipt
ever
ever dude i was just at the [ __ ] cash
register
yesterday if i want receipt that that
means i think you robbed me yeah and i'm
scrolling that thing by the way i bought
three things you know what i mean it's
not like they were like hey it's 18
grand i'm like hey you know
well some people bring their own bag
sure
losers as i call them
they usually have a yoga mat sticking
out of their back i know
they typically smell they probably
haven't showered that day too
that's what i'm saying
i don't know what he's talking they're
hippies
these are [ __ ] wacky tree huggers you
know no i'm kidding um i uh
my wife likes to do don't buy a bag yeah
we she brings them no she won't even
show like [ __ ] star load in our
pockets like i'm like i'm a [ __ ]
clown pulling out a [ __ ] rubber
chicken a never-ending handkerchief this
brawl's i'm like i'm not walking with a
six-pack of water in my pocket
get buy a [ __ ] bag it's crazy we
fight we get in hardcore we're gonna
just get a bag just get it back here we
don't need a bag i'm like yeah we might
not need one but i want a [ __ ] bag
get me a bag yeah those things are great
bag up shout out to reusable bags
brought to you by ayg's brought to you
this week by reusable bags
all right family company can't be mint
mobile mint mobile bent mobile mint
mobile
mint mobile
you use it i do my wife the lady's been
using it for years years before they
were even uh a sponsor and then
serendipity intervened and now we're a
part of the mint mobile family and you
could be too why pay all these uh hidden
fees and prices and this and that sure
mint mobile 15 beans a month you're in
and out no contract no nothing savings
passed and a tail yeah uh switching to
mobile is the easiest way to save this
year uh it's the first company itself
premium wireless service only online
lets you maximize your savings with
plans starting at just 15 beans a month
15 bucks 15 clams
uh all plans come with unlimited talk
tax high speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network
uh with mint mobile choose the amount of
monthly data that's right for you and
stop paying for data that you never use
switch to mint mobile and get premium
wireless service starting at 15 bucks a
month
to get your new wireless plan for just
15 bucks a month and get the plan
shipped to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com garbage that's
mintmobile.com garbage call your
wireless bill to 15 bucks a month mint
mobile.com garbage do it
butcher box uncle hank loves a good
butcher box gang if you like fresh top
quality meat delivered right to your
door butcher box is the answer best of
the best talking grass-fed beef we're
talking chicken we're talking
wild-caught salmon up there
pork fantastic yeah tastes better it's
more ethical ethical sustainable the
whole nine yards butcher boxes a
subscription service that takes the
guesswork out of finding high quality
meat ain't got to be poking around this
store that store hey you're not calling
up whole foods hey you got you got you
got meatballs butcher box takes care of
it there you go uh they sent us i mean
comically
large amount of meat it's good stuff
it's good stuff uh we're still working
through it it's so good one of my
favorite times of the week their ground
beef makes a hell of a bowl of
every month butcherbox ships a curated
selection of high quality meat right to
your home for free shipping and the
continental us no antibiotics no
hormones
uh each box contains between eight and
14 pounds of meat depending on the box
you choose that's enough for 24
individual meals what are we doing
uh this is your chance to never have to
shop for ground beef again because this
is the craziest thing i've ever said in
public that's right butcher box is
giving new members free ground beef for
life we call them and told them what do
you got we got
who's gonna pay for that plus you get a
10 off coupon what are we doing here
sign up for butcherbox sign up at
butcherbox.com ayg get two pounds of
ground beef free in every order for the
life of your membership plus a 10 off
coupon log on to butcherbox.com ayg to
claim this deal do it yeah now what do
you say we're getting a little questions
here yeah let's do it guys so as you
know when you sign up for the old uh
goddamn patreon over there we will
answer your garbage question on air uh
it's just the best way to do it patreon
gets first quick eating
this one uh this is more of a comment
this is from stacy's dad
anyone notice that the ayg gang's rise
in popularity uh popularity oddly
resembles the blues brothers kippy gets
a new ride they talk about a gig where
they drank more beer than money they
made
they get a gang together the bernies and
the sunglasses foley has likely ordered
two whole chickens and a coke
that's a deep cut
they've likely likely have used a song
and dance to get out of a jam likely
we'll end in an epic car chase through
chicago with them doing gigs in prison
oh that'd be awesome yeah me and you oh
we'll be killing it
plus the money i pick up on the side
selling that ass i know plus all the
loose season i'd be oh i'd be the bernie
king in that place
who needs two
that's [ __ ] great thank you so much
that was fun i wanted to get that out of
the game i'm surprised you got all that
did you get all that i mean
first of all it wasn't [ __ ] geometry
yeah i could put it together you know
because i figured you would have missed
the original blues bro i did miss the
original but like i've picked it up over
the years in chunks and whatever like
i've never like put it on and sat down
and watched it you ever seen it bozo
orange whip orange whip orange whip
three orange whips mr john candy
the ray charles seems the best when they
start doing that twist it
this car's got cop shocks
cop lighter cop engine mr dan aykroyd oh
yeah hung out with him one night
you were in the same room as him
tell ex what happened
i want to know exactly the
situation he was at the raven lounge one
time that's the story no before the our
show i had a threesome i had a threesome
with him and steve martin
and who was on the scene the mighty duck
man himself
emilio estevez
now he stood next to me for about three
seconds yeah but i did ask him about it
for a beer
[Laughter]
i i did ask him about ufos
because it was around he had just done a
documentary or something where he said
that he saw a ufo at his house in
upstate new york or wherever he lives
yeah
that's it what'd he say he's like oh
yeah that sucker did like a 4g dive or
something like that something real dan
aykroyd yeah then he walked away from me
yeah it sounds like hanging out to me
that sounds like me my buddies
my buddies always say three words to
each other and then walk away from each
other we haven't talked in a minute
it's busy what do you mean he's got you
think you would recognize you if you saw
you again no not without the beard
crazy
you didn't have a beard back then you
were clean-shaven in those days well
you're really poking holes in my tail
huh
that's how it's gonna be huh a little
hard feelings here on the air for
everybody all right uh this one's from
shane first time long time ever laid
down in smoke
man i remember watching my stepdad oh my
my dad pulled this move every saturday
exclusively yeah in the 1980s after
cutting the lawn mm-hmm
i remember my step dad
my mom used to let him smoke in the
house
when she didn't smoke
that's insane right it didn't smell as
bad as that maybe i just think cause
everything back that every play every
restaurant every bar everywhere you went
smelled like smoke so like you were
desensitized to it it was really
something like if somebody like them in
a house if somebody is going to my dad
we rip bernies yeah right we agree we
bernie ripper
somebody [ __ ] lit up a cigarette
while i was inside i'd [ __ ] lose it
what the [ __ ] is that yeah it's insane
but back then
dude my i remember my dad used to smoke
in people's houses who didn't smoke
it was just like understood he would
like hang out by the door like he would
at least go to like
the the deck door and be like yeah
looking back i'm like that's crazy
everything must have stunk back that's
everything
but everybody after sex like bernie's
laying in bed you ever pull that move
you ever roll over and light a cigarette
smoke in bed
after fornication chicken sandwich
no um
no never really i used to smoke in my
bed it's at temple we would smoke in the
apartment i'm sure that was real
attractive
was there a couple of couple of haters
you were you're poor i know you probably
smoked
at the titan street house laying in bed
not little porker no i never smoked in
that room i don't know we smoked in that
house did we i can't remember i thought
we did you probably did
[ __ ] huffing
huffing cleaning products in the
basement after lights out all bets are
off you know what i mean was there a
ceiling fan to for you to look up at and
remember the war
no
there was yeah i feel like you have to
go through some [ __ ] to be able to do
that yeah but the ceiling fan with the
lay down sig is key i feel 100
uh i remember myself that was laying on
the couch at my mom's like on his back
and he was smoking he was trying not to
ash
because i guess that means he had to
like get up or whatever and ash the
scene
was he rocking a thick pinky
what was he rocking a pinky what's a
pinky you don't know what a pinky is no
toby i assume it's like a grandma ash
yeah long ass
pinkies uh but i was like it became a
game of me my me and my brother were
sitting next to him on the couch and
we're like see how long you can go and
he was just laying straight back like a
vampire [ __ ] chief in this thing and
dude he got like all the way we're like
go go i was like looking that hit me
today i'm like we were [ __ ] dirt back
dude cheering on a guy smoking a cig
that's the trashiest [ __ ] i ever heard
[ __ ] dirtbag jenga yes that's extreme
making a game of lung cancer
we were like go go go you can do it i do
too paul
put one in your butthole yeah
man real [ __ ] real trashy he ever fall
asleep with him in his hand i don't i
mean no he wasn't into pills at that
time i think so that's like
i mean that's only narcotics no one
falls asleep while smoking you put this
sick yeah grandmas will do that don't
fall asleep no
no i mean yeah okay if you're 90 sure
and oxygen is getting cut off to your
head but other than that you put the
bernie down pills
like elvis
falling asleep with sunglasses on
got burnt holes in your pants and [ __ ]
so many kids would show up which i would
used to hang out with show up with
[ __ ] burn holes all over their
clothes the yellow on the fingers as a
kid that's real that's real coal miners
daughter [ __ ] right there
[Laughter]
dude
that's like this boy's life do you knew
any [ __ ] 12 or 13 year olds that had
those burn hands oh man his dad hit him
for sure yeah it's a tough look
um
all right let's see here this is this is
from clark do you know all the steps to
the electric slide that's just funny
[Laughter]
i
missed it was
i was too young i think when it was like
really cook and it would have been like
the [ __ ]
70s no the electric slides was the 90s
80s i don't think so oh yeah not
definitely not the 90s yeah it was yeah
it was it was 90s yes for sure dang i
was probably like seven to the point
where i'm like i'll lay off the pills
i can only have to peyote as a
seven-year-old fat kid you're not like
let me learn this communal dance and
dance with everybody you know what i
mean i hung out near the [ __ ] buffet
table at the end where the rolls were i
that was like those were like the first
things where you know like i'll like
hate something
just for no reason like the world yeah
yeah uh that was like where that started
because i felt self-conscious about
myself of course i never learned that or
limbo when it was time for limbo i
disappeared like batman i know
i remember doing it a couple of times
but just like obviously i didn't have i
was top heavy you know what i mean i
would go i would go back too quick
teacher stop [ __ ] whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa yeah whenever
that [ __ ] whenever that that got broken
out at the seventh and eighth grade
dances i would just go sit in the
bathroom pretend like i was taking a
deuce because that's better you'd right
you'd rather be the fat kid [ __ ]
than [ __ ] the kid who couldn't do the
limbo
follow jesus limbo now i got diarrhea
where you guys going after it was taco
tuesday yeah i never learned any of that
[ __ ] the macarena well that was i mean
that was big i'm jealous i'm jealous
but i'll sit there at the table at a
wedding like an [ __ ]
you won't get up and dance at a wedding
not really i'll dance with the bride
take her for a spin you know what i mean
you're doing that thing where you got
her on each side
put her under your legs and [ __ ]
you're doing a sock hop and stuff
turn it to christopher walken real quick
[Music]
you're doing dirty dancing with the
[ __ ] with the bride it's my wedding
night
what was that called one more night what
was that called lamacha what was that
called dirty dancing no that dance this
it's a spanish word
la macha something like that
morenga karma sutra no no
that's a bit of jerry's flavor isn't it
that karma subject
that's when you know that's when you
take the horny goat weed toby you know
what i'm talking about the seductive
dance the dirty mambo no no no no there
was a movie made about it dirty dancing
calypso no calypso what
colombo it's an emperor isn't it dirty
dancing no it wasn't there's a name for
it there's a spanish name for it for the
for that kind of morenga not the morenga
lemon meringue
key lime pie
scoops ice cream
ah god damn it people are probably
screaming at the tv right now the cha
cha the cha-cha slide the cha-cha
it was it came out in the 90s the fox
trot
charleston the bugle boy company b
no no it's called like uh
[ __ ]
i got i'm looking right now what dance
does johnny teach baby no no i'm not
talking about in dirty dancing i'm not
telling you but it is dirty it's like
who literally said the dance from dirty
dancing did i yeah i just meant dirty
it's like dirty dancing it's sexual
my irish catholic roots wouldn't let me
say the word that's where that came from
dirty dancing what they would go out and
do dirty dancing like [ __ ] you know
bumping and grinding yeah that's where
it came we go out and do the dirty
backstop yeah just twerking just for you
working in the 50s bachata
not the machado bloodshot uh not la
bamba
de la bata
there's a lot of me no la bomba no
all right that's enough of this
it's called something
some kind of
it's spanish word for dirty dancing
it's lost something
la tortuga
that's what you look like right now
a turtle turtle coming out of his shell
the green shirt and no beard
that one no
i know the bumba richie valens
died in the same plane crashes uh buddy
holly
didn't he i think he did
anyway what was the question i don't
know uh did you ever go dirty dancing no
what was the question
i forget
i don't know what are you doing over
there what are you looking at don't give
him a list pornhub
merengue it's not merengue you already
did merengue listen he wouldn't know if
you said it people i guarantee people
are screaming it was real popular
samba no
mambo no number five number six
shout out to lou bega
that's the name of the dance
yeah lube what do when lou beggar hit
wasn't like a big band guy he had like a
like an old hat
yeah he wore like a zoot suit right yeah
a little zoot suit he was german real
good to find out
yeah i mean he's not even i think he
yeah he plays like dominican or
something but he's shaggy does
that was another one when that dropped
it wasn't me dropped whoo
that's a monster that was at the top of
the charts for like a deck if you
weren't singing that in traffic
that thing gets cranked yeah for sure
um all right let's see here uh
this is from jeremy first time long time
ever wear your shoes as slippers
i feel like where you step on the heel i
guess oh
i feel like that could be a you thing
yeah there's certain pairs of sneakers
they got to be real real beat up yeah to
do it yeah yeah you wear wear it in
public like that
you'll go to the store with your with
your heels hanging out i ca i mean i
would if i could pull it off but i can't
pull it off as far as my walking
technique i just walk out of them
i'll just step out of them yeah i can
barely use flip-flops
i always slide out of them really i
can't use slides i come they're like the
wheels going off
tighten the lug nuts on them yeah i
thought that was cool back in the day
what when people would do that they'd
break in like a pair of stan
stan steves that's crazy what's that
guy's name stan lee snow stan smith dan
smith yeah pair of those all broken in
that's crazy my wife does it sometimes
with her sometimes she'll do it with my
shoes because they're bigger so she can
like does she flatten it she will what
i would freak the [ __ ] out
my whole life i think he's trying to
keep that plastic thing from digging
into my heel yeah because i i already do
it bad because i never untie my shoes i
just [ __ ] wiggle them in there
i seen you at airport security oh yeah
um she does it i should drives me
[ __ ] crazy freak out i would freak
out drives me nothing but what are you
doing it's a hundred dollars if it's an
old pair of sneakers yeah yeah if i
don't wear them anymore sure for me to
stop wearing a pair of shoes they're on
the back end
those things are done
they smell there's a hole in them like
there's no way
you can just casually wear an old pair
of my shoes they're it's it's a it's oh
yeah it's done yeah yeah i wear them to
the point where i smell them and i go
these are i can smell them sitting here
recording i go these gotta go i did i
pulled that move in uh syracuse or
wherever we were at hartford yeah yeah i
walked in with them and threw them out
because they stunk tommy was trying to
eat his quesadilla that at the maggie
mcfly's yeah and he was getting all
barfed up
cause he could smell my face you said to
my feet and i said what do you keep them
in your [ __ ]
uh all right this is from timbo slice is
it garbage to stand up for a t-shirt
toss as an adult
i don't know man what yes dude
if you're trying to get it for a kid
sure that's that if you're out with you
and your wife and they got the t-shirt
count and you're going for it if you're
going over here over here it's a bad
luck uh it depends how listen i would
never be one of those guys that would
like die for a ball or something like
that
i would never make meatballs a hard
physicist
the meatball cannon
right here baby
[Laughter]
shoot me in the back of the head lay me
up dude
she even get in my mouth from right
field
uh i would never do anything like that
just because you don't want to be the
guy falling or this or that um
but i don't know man that t-shirt guy he
stands up with that [ __ ] gun you get
[ __ ] pumped up you just want to grab
it
if it came in my general direction i
would i would go for it but then i think
it would have to be
really it would have to just be like
you'd be you'd have to get out of the
way it's the only way i would go for it
you can't be reaching down over somebody
no i would never do that well i'm saying
otherwise it's got to come right to your
[ __ ] grill yeah if it was in my zone
i'm not gonna let the team down i'm
gonna [ __ ] try to make the play
but i think the reason we're down 15 at
half but
that fat guy just got that t-shirt if he
can do it we can do it can't fit in the
shirt but still he got it uh
the unwritten rule as an adult male with
any of that stuff
a baseball a [ __ ] pair of sneak
anything that a [ __ ] player gives you
or get that's got to go right to a
little kid oh yeah that's gotta unless
your girl wants the t-shirt or whatever
but yeah if you're a [ __ ] guy and
you're taking a ball home
that's
you know
that's crazy
yeah yeah you gotta give it to a yeah
always gotta give it to it always always
go to a kid for sure gang let's talk
about the good people that bespoke post
box of awesome box of awesome the most
awesomest box in all the land absolutely
fantastic let me tell you something
right now spring's coming you want some
cool stuff let's cut the [ __ ] let's
cut to the nitty-gritty should i get my
knife out the bespoke post sent me cut
this [ __ ] i'm not gonna be reading
the copy i'm gonna tell you the straight
truth it's cool guys stuff
for [ __ ] cool guys yeah and they're
[ __ ]
uh small businesses that they get the
stuff from they're quality [ __ ] made
unique goods pocket knives grooming
material [ __ ] for the outdoors stuff for
the home bar it's top shelf cool stuff
that you want to have around so you can
flex on people yeah it is a face throw
to get started take the quiz at box of
austin.com your answers are going to
help them pick the right box for you uh
release new boxes every month across a
ton of different categories you can say
cocktails outdoor travel the whole nine
yards uh it's free to sign up you can
skip a month at any time each box is
valued at around 70 bucks but you only
pay a fraction of that price what are we
donating 40 bucks or something that's
nuts plus each box of awesome you're
supporting small business like the big
man said ninety percent of everything
comes from your box of awesomeness from
a small up-and-coming brand to get 20
off your first monthly box when you sign
up at box of austin.com enter the promo
code garbage at check out that's box of
awesome dot com code garbage for 20 off
your first box box of awesome.com gold
garbage do it let's talk about blue chew
blue chew new sponsor baby to good stuff
let's go time to get off the couch
yeah and if the pump's not working what
do you do you go to the blue chew if the
pump is working you [ __ ] double down
as lagasse says take it up a notch let's
let it ride yeah [ __ ] springtime's
coming the rabbits are running around
wild now gotta take care of it let's go
get in the game get off the bench and
into the game blue chew is a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
but in chewable tablets at a fraction of
the cost take them any time day or night
so you can plan ahead or be ready for
whenever whenever the opportunity all
right oh
uh the process never know when the
doorbell's gonna ring you know what i
mean the process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll get a free you'll
receive your prescription within days
best part it's all done online no visits
to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations no waiting in line at the
pharmacy bluetooth tablets are made in
the good old us of a there you go uh
homegrown boners and prepared and
shipped directly to your door in a
discreet package is that in the copy
homegrown banner no that's a kippy
homegrown boners is all right
that's a great punk band
uh so if you could benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to perform
bluetooth can help as we've got a
special deal for our listeners try
bluetooth free
for free when you use our promo code
garbage at checkout just pay five bucks
for shipping that's bluetooth.com promo
code garbage to receive your first month
free visit bluetooth.com for details and
important safety information we thank
bluechu for sponsoring this podcast now
back to the show yeah
uh this one's from greg sullivan haven't
had one read yet is it garbage to let a
company fly you out and your spouse for
an interview and use it as a vacation
knowingly you're not going to take the
job damn that's in a [ __ ] good
position that's a [ __ ] chestnut
checkers movie yeah right [ __ ] there
who's doing that i don't i've never been
in an interview where i didn't
desperately need the job i've never been
including this one
i've never been in a position where
someone's like do you wanna get up we'll
pay a hundred bucks for you to fly out
here ever and what company [ __ ]
brings the bird with you too i guess it
get you like a companion you know what i
mean like we'll fly you know i guess if
that's that's white collar [ __ ] yeah
they're not flying out people for pet
boys
hey how are you with spark plugs bring
the family for a week because i remember
the dirt ball dream of a lot of people i
worked at in corporate restaurants was
yeah i'm trying to get that promotion
i'm trying to get them to transfer me to
hawaii they put yeah it was like fort
lauderdale there's always there's always
like the holy grail of chain restaurants
yeah you can land that yeah yeah i might
be able to get the sous chef down there
in fort lauderdale maybe be a manager my
boy pulled an all-time move he got flown
down to a conference in miami where they
paid for the hotel in the rental car he
flew his wife down they took the company
rental car drove to key west he didn't
step one foot in the conference flew
back they called him into the meeting
and they said hey buddy great job down
there at the
it conference that you you [ __ ] your
corporate bigwigs i don't know what you
did down there but you sure as i made an
impression on the old man i can tell you
that
that's like when wilhelm does the
project already
wow that's a [ __ ] baller move right
there that's [ __ ] that could have
went south though
it doesn't matter he's down there with
his feet and his tootsies in the sand a
corona he's got the bird with him so
what'd you think about these new i-95
reports
like i was telling him at the conference
that's great he's got sunburn on one
side of his face
the one time i went on an interview and
i got it it was for like flavia or
something it was again it was like a
glavia yeah let me find out what it was
yeah what are you pushing some off-brand
sweetener no it was a it was a coffee
machine
it was a coffee machine it's like equal
but it kills you twice as fast flavia it
was a coffee machine
that sounds like some rockefeller
records would be interesting
it's just a bottle of flavor dr dre's
new sweetener substitute i think my
aunt's getting class-action lawsuits
checked from that [ __ ]
up yeah so no
have you been exposed
have you where a loved one developed
mesothelioma due to exposure to flavia
you may be entitled to one lump sum
um it was like a subsidiary of m ms it
was i found it in the paper
in college
and i what are you going to do there
sell sell chocolatier sell coffee
machines
it was a coffee machine i'm thinking of
lava and uh well that's good stuff
though plaza yeah
that's all right i don't know where it
actually was the soap from the 80s yeah
that's
that sounds pretty good too just had
rocks in it yeah the sands all right
you're both such dirt bags it's lavazza
whatever
those machines are right yeah george
clooney zip it yeah
hey why don't you take a stop over lake
who gives a [ __ ]
go give your buddies a million bucks
and i was like i was like oh man this is
i got the job and i remember i wore a
red tie because they were like red shows
powers like it was like something that i
read in business school or something so
i wore a red tie or a red suit
[Laughter]
dressed like [ __ ] steve harvey this
guy walks in dressed like the devil
i'll take your flavia
[Laughter]
and i was the kind of job interviews i
would get was you found it in the paper
was it an open call and i showed up he's
like listen you seem like a good guy
i'll hire you i'm like oh thank you mr
businessman he's like give me a check
for 219 bucks a day you got to buy the
machine to be able to sell it i'm like
i was like hey jokes on you i don't have
a checkbook
but this says what's this gentleman's
name again uh do you know it is
it was greg
because let me tell you something that's
gotta be a good wike you got a good job
no people are if there's suitors after
you to try to get you yeah he does
something sir he makes a lot of coin
like i said i've never gone on an
interview where i didn't [ __ ]
desperately need the job and would have
done anything they'd be like we'll give
you a half a minimum wage i'd like i'm
in and nobody was flying me anywhere no
no that's nuts
that's like finance
sales
yeah probably insurance type plumber i
don't know something
i bring my own wrenches
that's high-tech that's that's great
yeah that's i i don't know that's got to
be the norm
i mean that's a ball or move but i would
assume dudes like that are doing that
all the time i'll just just like going
out there and hearing what they have to
say
that's man yeah you're taking calls you
know what i mean like you're just
peeping you're seeing you're kicking the
tires out there on jobs
any podcasts want to fly me out to uh to
interview you can have them
yeah that's great that's a that's a
[ __ ] chess move i love that yeah it's
a [ __ ] ball anytime you pull the
[ __ ] wool over those [ __ ]
corporations eyes i'm in well i mean
they say bring that that's probably they
know that they know they know he's
bringing the late bring the lady stay
for the weekend you can we gotta think
there's they think they're well they're
whining and dying they're wanting to
dine and probably get a couple lakers
tickets whatever they need
it's [ __ ] nice yeah
that's a [ __ ] that's a that's a kj
move right there that's pretty i respect
that
um all right this one's from fantina
fentana uh never had one red ever forget
all the bathroom towels are in the
washer end up washing your hands and
having to pat them dry on the shower
curtain oh never the shower curtain did
it today the shower curtain yeah the one
on the outside not the plastic one yeah
yeah well this goddamn dog's [ __ ] got
everything everything's dirty it's a
mess it's in the whatever [ __ ] wash
my hands today
looking around [ __ ] shower curtain
was right there had them dry real nice
pretty good pretty good clean you know
yeah it's all right i'll give it to you
yeah i go for the washcloth i'm not
supposed to touch or the she has this
like wrap that wraps up her hair that's
almost like a shamwow material yeah yeah
i'm not supposed to touch it i know
there's a couple things that i'm not a
lot of touch oh yeah of course dude i'll
like wipe my face on a robe or whatever
just [ __ ] barbecue sauce [ __ ] oh yeah
i don't give a [ __ ] she's like what's
this i'm like
that reminds me i had a question for you
guys where is your bath towel currently
is it on the towel rack no it's hanging
over the door going into the office
hanging over a closet door
sideways not like folded up it's like
thrown over the corner yeah the air out
yeah you gotta get you got to give the
surface area time to dry out otherwise
it stinks then you stink yeah where do
you put yours oh you have one yeah
oh yeah like that was a possibility that
you were gonna say no over the showers
trash that's where mine is
you do it over the shout like unfold it
out over the shower we don't unfold it
like you know like just thrown over once
to dry it out maybe really yeah it
depends we should do it we put the
bathmat up there
let that's right yeah why it yeah you
put the bath mat up there when it gets
wet
when you get done in the shower or why
you're cleaning the the floor
maybe yeah
well i imagine the red cross has to put
sandbags down when you get in the
shower big man
big man's bathing
there's one of those daisy chains and
people all just handing bags to each
other through your apartment the
community really pulls together
but i happen to shower i will say that
better better pay your flood insurance
here he's taking a bath tomorrow
i thought i was going to [ __ ] about
shower curtains because i do have that
problem [ __ ] gets everywhere and the
thing attacks me in the shower too
the shower curtain
because i'm soaked i'm closing the
static or something but your dad's all
wrapped up like you're fighting a squid
brutal that's like ursula's got you yeah
[ __ ] 20 000 leagues under the tub
uh
yeah that's tough i got a bad situation
now cause i got a lot of shower pressure
a lot of water pressure coming out of
that thing but when it turns too much
it lifts up the shower curtain if that
makes sense you get like a br you get
like a breeze goes under there because
and then it attacks you yeah yeah it's
on your legs and [ __ ] and you're [ __ ]
i don't like i gotta find the perfect
the perfect uh velocity coming out i
want a [ __ ] uh
a glass one what do you mean even like a
plastic door yeah you're a doorman i
would love that yeah or like the way the
hotels have the one that goes out a
little bit it's real nice yeah gives you
a little bit of [ __ ] wiggle room in
there dude buy the whole business by the
way we stayed at a holiday inn express
in tampa
but my [ __ ] hot my bathroom was
disgusting it looked like the before
picture in like an infomercial where
they're like for like clr or something
where like they used to think there was
[ __ ] there was lime build up there
was [ __ ] calcium it was like a cave
in that [ __ ] stalactites in your
shower tough tough tough tough
um this one's just funny this is from
low t-79 uh we've talked about above
ground pools have you ever had an above
ground pool collapse
that is a tough look
growing up we had a kid
it was my friend's neighbor
and they didn't have any water in it and
the trees had already grown like grown
through so it was just like the shell
what his name was mark he was really
into wrestling
a little too old by the way to be into
wrestling high school wrestling no
wwe from the top ropes wrestling
wait a minute let me picture girls
lurking around there so you have an
above-ground pool
with no water in it trees
i think they probably didn't open it for
a season or two due to financial
hardship
and then you know
roots or something and then like you
lose it for a year you look in a pool
and you see [ __ ] grass and [ __ ]
growing it's bad no like i'm talking
like proper trees proper like you know
yeah like a
tree
like bushes and [ __ ] they do it now
people that buy the
like the semi
like
you're supposed to dispose of it
yeah you know i'm like the ones that
have like the pvc piping sure there's
always some fat lady cutting those open
oh and they get taken out she gets taken
out
the kids come flying out in the [ __ ]
and they're little uh little floaties
those aren't those are like uh
not seasonal but like i think two tree
seasons like you get you get like two
blow-ups on them and then that's a wrap
you know
those i've seen
but i think somebody in our neighborhood
when i was younger in the first
neighborhood we lived in theirs
collapsed that was like the big news and
the pool collapsed
like everybody was worried about like
flooding in their basement and [ __ ] like
that oh flooded in the basement
tough luck you got a sump pump down
there we do but i mean we get got every
like maybe five or six years it'll flood
yeah that's a real good smell you ever
seen a kid fall through a trampoline
that's a good time
i've fallen off a couple of times dude
the construction on those things in the
80s was [ __ ] downright child abuse
dude again we ne we were never able to
just do anything the way everybody was
doing it we always knew a guy or had a
thing or something
and my stepdad everybody's getting
trampolines early 90s mid 90s that's
when they're booming
we didn't have you had three mattresses
on top of each other
with six old-timey firefighters
yar kevin wants to bounce
um
we didn't have the circle [ __ ] we had a
square trampoline it was like a gymnast
trampoline where my stepdad's like i
know a guy who's got one
and then that thing showed up it was
huge and green and the spring remember
the springs on like the circle ones were
like this long and there was like
500 of them around the thing so you
couldn't fall through it yeah we just
had like ours were like this long
and there was like six on each side
and dude i mean that's for like earth
moving equipment dude it was like yeah
it looked like they were like shocks
dude
i mean kids were getting [ __ ] up on
this thing
hardcore called it the eliminator oh man
[ __ ] cracking heads open and then
they'd be like all right take it easy
next i'm surprised my mom didn't shut it
down walking like taffer and shut it
down dude those things were deadly man
we had dope pads no nothing
no like you remember like they would
have like the blue ring of the pattern
we didn't have anything
[ __ ] kids where you'd fall through
because your legs could go through the
springs you get [ __ ] gooched real
quick those springs [ __ ] seal up on
your little eight-year-old nut sack dude
you pinch the inside skin in your
[ __ ] thigh
yeah it was always fun to go under them
too
oh yeah or in the rain uh the rain was a
good time yeah i remember my neighbor
fell really hard on the monkey bars like
in the middle
and uh i don't know how old she could
have been maybe 11 or 12 and it like
caused her to have her period what yeah
her mom like told her
[Laughter]
i'm kidding i'm kidding i'll get it
obviously
[Laughter]
never talk to her
after that
no but i remember that dude that [ __ ]
like i'm talking [ __ ] happened yeah i'm
talking one of those those fear monkey
fear my half sphere monkey bars those
things they were deadly those things
were not caught up in one of those
uh-huh
[ __ ] nightmare i remember we had this
big stainless steel slide at like our at
my elementary school about 400 degrees
in the summer man would be cooking and
they'd make you go down and kids would
be crying and [ __ ] exactly oh my gosh
cook making eggs yeah
how do you want them
over easy come down you slide into an
omelette
man torching your legs i can feel it now
puckers up your butthole they've really
come a long way with all that stuff
because the playground now there's like
chopped up foam so you can't tires and
stuff yeah it's [ __ ] really really
nice
that was another thing we had tires did
you have tires on your playground what
do you mean just tires like huge
semi-truck tires that would be like four
feet tall and they would bury like half
of them
so you could like kind of you would go
in inside yeah yeah yeah 100 or like
jump from one to the other yeah but it
was also like chopped up like like wood
chips they started doing that yeah yeah
that's pretty trashy having one of those
the big construction tire that having a
little bulldozer that could move around
and think that was a good time though
what are you talking about i was moving
some earth back in the day
eating your cdl to get that that was the
foreman hey listen i need this over
there by the end of lunch break go
one kid playing two guys stealing around
holding holding clipboards
what are you doing
not paying you to stand there jerkle
that's pretty funny goddamn union shop
[Laughter]
um all right let's see
this is from trevor again we've talked
about satellite dishes does that do you
or anyone in your family have a
satellite dish on their house that's not
being used
i don't think we've ever talked about
that my dad's never trusted that
wouldn't any uh what is it directv right
now get out of here there were a couple
of psychos in the 80s
that actually had like the huge big one
in the backyard yeah i thought i always
thought they were aliens because i never
trusted those [ __ ] uh who were you
talking it was always how many channels
do you need they never had kids no they
were like in their 40s they didn't have
kids they have like a couple dogs they
would pour like a concrete pad in the
back and then put like a mega [ __ ]
six foot diameter there's one in my
neighborhood right now
it's crazy
in the [ __ ] backyard i don't know
some [ __ ] astronaut or something i
don't [ __ ] know
it's exactly what i'm talking about some
dude some some like family with no kids
ninth i don't know what who what were
they for toby do you have any idea what
they were for
channels i think that was just the
technology at the time
but what were you getting yeah like the
90s what were you getting on it hbo
there's no way you need you need a
structural a thing built in your
backyard to get hbo i had hbo now listen
this isn't tv this is hbo so we're going
to have to put an edition on that i
don't think he's going to take a second
mortgage to fund this hbo wasn't
broadcasting over satellite it was a
cable
you wouldn't be able to pick it up i got
to be honest i don't know the difference
we were not an hbo family either so
my dad you were a cable family
yeah that was being run through cable
not a [ __ ] [ __ ] comcast that
wasn't satellite would hp don't have a
satellite in the [ __ ] 90s
i don't know i don't know anything i'm
not even sure what satellites do it's a
real suspect what they do is they cut
out when it's rainy i don't [ __ ] ruin
a saturday afternoon you look like a
direct tv household we had it at one
point oh yeah figures
yeah dude it would get cloudy out and
the [ __ ] would cut out it was
infuriating i never got is that
what is the benefit to it i do remember
they'd be like we have seven million
channels or whatever it's in places
where the cable's not laid
that's why that's what i think initially
it was for laying the cable was a pain
in the
ass you just [ __ ] throw a satellite
up there remember when they redid when
they remember they changed everything
everything over to fiber optics and they
tore up everybody's yards and stuff
delayed that cable i remember all my
dirtbag friends were trying to get jobs
and get get job laying the fiber optics
i'll be set me and my brother did that
rewiring happen horsham yeah high school
for a summer we only lasted a couple of
weeks because we weren't union and we
didn't know what we were doing
they're in the cafeterias
now they put me and him up in the
[ __ ] uh drop ceilings yeah because we
were like small enough and light enough
when we crawl around in there and
[ __ ] pull the thing i remember that
summer coughing up [ __ ] fiberglass
like weeks after [ __ ] we did the job
switching newports huh
bought my first car with that money i
remember one time when i we found out
what asbestos was working construction
on my dad i'm like i think that's
asbestos yeah you're good i'm like
that's when like you were at the height
of the met the [ __ ] class action
lawsuit oh yeah and i remember being
like
i don't know about this i mean i'm
sitting there smoking [ __ ] cranking
bernies
asbestos cigarettes
um
all right this is uh from zach
where i live it isn't uncommon to have
two to three different type of dead
animals decorating the living room walls
is that garbage have any sort of
taxidermy in the living room
hmm
i grew up around some hunters
hunters
i think the living room might be a bit
of a tough look a den a basement a
garage uh something i get that a living
room i feel like a living if not
everybody's a hunter say you're a
hunting family mom hunts dad hunts
little kids mom hunts mom hunts
i get that but like i don't know that
seems like tough to have like a [ __ ]
the problem is the taxidermy usually
isn't
the most artistic
it's not that great no like the the
bear's head looks a little weird
you know what i mean the one deer's
eyeballs going one way sure
[ __ ] moose wearing sunglasses
it's no good and it's really off-putting
when it's in your face like it doesn't
look like in the movies like it looks
like that bear's head's like small
you're like oh it looks like a dog yeah
no good
uh
i've seen them done nice they can be
done nice my my stepdad family was
really big into it the bears the [ __ ]
whatever they had like a bear rug and
like all this [ __ ]
uh
his dad was really into the birds like
quails and stuff no
sitting on a fake branch yeah all that
stuff and he redid the whole i just saw
it it scared the [ __ ] out of me over the
summer i don't know i never told you
this scared the [ __ ] bejesus out of
me uh i went to his house for the first
time dude and it was like that cnn's
friend tour when all the animals are
[ __ ] looking at you he had hundreds
of birds on the wall it
petrified me it was an old house too
from like the early 1900s you could feel
like a cold come through the living room
i was like yo start the car we're
[ __ ] out of here dude
dead birds in a draft i mean yeah you
can feel the ghost creeping in on you
the [ __ ] evil spirits will get you
yeah no man it's not good to have that
many dead things in the house
yikes
um all right this is from spencer you
ever stick your feet out the window of a
car or been in a car with someone doing
it i feel the ladies do that a lot guys
can't really get away with big move
your lady does it no no my lady doesn't
do it but that's a big move with the
ladies yeah yeah my wife puts them on
the dashboard i'm like you what are we
doing meanwhile if i rear-end somebody
your [ __ ] knees are halfway out your
[ __ ] yeah it's no good yeah now no
good
driving with your knee anything dumb
like that i'll do i mean i'll do a need
you'll do a knee not like i'm not
celebrating i feel like that was
like if i kind of smoke a bowl you know
what i mean i got a [ __ ] try to rip
the song
as t-bone would say
you gotta have a [ __ ] you know what i
mean i thought you have some coverage i
always thought that was a hot chick move
what drive with your knee it was real
sexy in high school
you should wait wait do you see me do it
i really get you chubbed up
your varicose vein thigh
big milky white thighs
uh we were talking about that weren't we
talking about varicose veins
this weekend probably you and your
doctor
i don't know but i got him uh i got a
bruise on my shin it's there for life
you're like a bad peach
[Laughter]
i got mac and all peach this one over
here my shins are like half off bananas
[ __ ] bad
uh let's do a couple more here this is
from david never had a question right is
it garbage to purposely
blow a red light we're talking 2 3 a.m
thoughts on that because you're a very
cautious driver
i am i would never blow a red light
straight i'll make it right on red
when i'm at night looking for how about
going straight will you stop poke around
two tree in the morning no one around
you're kind of in like a parking lot not
really it's like when will you blow a
red light if i get scared if he buys you
a drink
if you got coke on them um
if i get sometimes
at a red light like that like where
there's no one around in the middle of
the night like down in the burbs when
you're out there no street lights and
[ __ ] i get i get scared you think the
boogeyman's i think the boogeyman yeah
i'm just what is it about the suburbs
where the book you know the boogeyman
can't live in the city the men and women
get out to the burbs
they're everywhere apparition comes out
of the woods it's right next to your
window yeah
there's rabbits with antlers weren't
that that was a thing in the 90s wasn't
it jackals or something wasn't that on
america's funniest videos am i crazy
i feel like america's funniest videos
was a rabbit with antlers ooh i don't
that's not funny at all i don't like
that
yeah rabbit with antlers
i would lose it sounds real true
detective stuff this guy
the jackalope what's it doing is it a
real thing
it's a frankenstein rabbit is the
stuffed nightmare i don't know if it's
real or not
it's a mythical animal of north american
folklore or my dreams
[Laughter]
yeah jack rabbit with antelope horns who
lives behind wawa's
only comes out for fourth meal
the jackal rabbit yeah jackalope i'll do
it then however
most of those uh intersections in small
towns
you can uh if you draw if you pull up
and then pull back a little bit you can
register the sensor i look oh i pulled
up the sensor always i always do
a little back trip it's i'm out of there
yeah we just did it in at four leaving
the hotel 430 tampo remember it was
t-bone i'm like can i can i make a right
on this red here even goes four o'clock
in the morning in tampa again
[ __ ] laid wheels out of there daddy
uh i had to fly to return a car in a
flight to catch that might be the
coolest thing you've ever said
i like your set of enemies too
turn into sam elliott real quick
he let my he lit a cigarette and handed
it to me that's a power move when
someone's like let me get a sig and you
hand them that one you ever like light a
sig i'd do it with my girl really when
she you wouldn't take would you take
that from toby no we were we were living
in a bit oh okay i thought it really
happened no
smoking in a rental car
4 30 in tampa it sounds like anything
goes very true um but that was a move
too yeah like i'd be like late and say
with my wife be like oh can i have one
back when we were dating you know she
gave her that one boom right now
sexy yeah it's a real [ __ ] james dean
or jimmy dean steve martin had the best
one of those i can't remember what movie
it was in he had an unfiltered cigarette
he lights the one end his last zig
lights the front end flips it around
lights the other end and then breaks it
in half and hands it to her
fire steve martin did this yeah
maybe three amigos
or roxanne could have been roxanne i
think it was something where's plaid
oh dead men don't wear plaid all right
this is uh let's do this and we gotta
get out of here this is from scott is a
garbage take a spray of cologne from the
men's bathroom attendant
yeah yeah what do you think what are the
chances that they got the same stuff
you're wearing too
i assume like if you're wear you can't
be in the middle of a date
right or out to dinner
can't yeah go away go in smell and go
and you know all that
go go and smell like eternity come out
smelling like jakar yeah that's weird
what are you doing in there i know use
it listen i know that's somebody's job
maybe a lucy every now and then at the
nightclubs or whatever lucy they'll have
six they'll have new ports oh really i
have a pack of new ports and a pack of
marble lights
so if you're like you know poop cigs
yeah you know no it's not for using an
errands for going around having a bernie
but they've been there pooped up yeah
pooping at nightclubs like that
i mean i understand i get what you're
saying i'm not listen am i am i in that
nightclub then there's people
i've been in a position where you've
been hemmed up and can use a little
night cap if no one's got bernie's you
go oh [ __ ]
johnny downstairs got bernie i thought
you've been taking a dump in a club i've
done that for sure at davios no it was
like red sky or something
there's a brown sky after i got done
with it
you shouldn't be using those guys i mean
after covid
i don't know some guys
they're probably yeah they probably mean
you feel bad at somebody's job but none
and you ain't taking anything from those
guys a mint maybe a piece of gum he's
got a wintergreen lifesaver i'm not
gonna individually wrap lifesaver i mean
it's not like you're grabbing a bowl of
m ms or something like these are [ __ ]
copping some dumplings hypoallergenic
seal
you go to the bathroom there's chex mix
in there
making a meatball sandwich where the
cheese is
oh man bathroom attended chex mix
tough luck
all right listen bozos let's wrap it up
we're getting the [ __ ] out of here
remember what i said los angeles
california la jolla california and san
francisco california let's move
something next
baby and then that same month what
detroit buffalo and pittsburgh yeah
those are already cooked just get your
tickets come out the live shows are a
great time some stand up some ayg a
whole lot of fun a lot of fun don't get
too drunk see you next week peace